>> This is Rick Warren author of The Purpose
Driven Life and pastor of Saddleback Church.
I'm here at Davos with a lot of my friends
and we're talking about what are the biggest
problems on the planet and how are we going
to solve them.
Right now I think there are five that I call
global giants: extreme poverty, pandemic diseases,
illiteracy, corruption and the spiritual emptiness.
These problems are so big nobody's been able
to solve them. The US hasn't solved them,
the UN hasn't solved them, nobody's solved
them. And I think it's because it's going
to take a three-pronged strategy to do this.
There is a role for the public sector, there
is a role for the private sector and there
is a role for the faith sector. Each of them
can do something that none of the other three
can do.
Government has a role to set agenda, government
has a role to set priorities and things like
that and move nations. And there are some
things that only governments can do.
Businesses have a role which they have: they
bring expertise, they bring investments, they
bring all kinds of innovations to the market.
But then, also, houses of worship have things
that businesses and government will never
have. In the first place, we have universal
distribution. The church was global 200 years
before Davos started talking about globalization.
I could take you to 10 million villages around
the world and the only thing in it is a church.
And we are in more locations than the United
Nations, we speak more languages than the
United Nations, we're in a thousand more people
groups than the United Nations.
You see there are 600 million Buddhists in
the world, there are 800 million Hindus in
the world, there are a billion Muslims in
the world, but there are 2.3 billion Christians
in the world. If you take people of faith
out of the equation, you've ruled out five-sixths
of the world.
So we have to mobilize this, these faith groups
to do, work together on these issues that
have been unsolvable. And the church has of
course the greatest distribution. They also
have the biggest manpower with 2.3 billion
people. That means the church, the Christian
church is bigger than China. It's bigger than
India. In fact, it's bigger than India and
China put together. So nothing compares to
its size. We have hundreds of millions of
people who volunteer around the world in villages
and cities on a weekly basis. And we don't
have to pay them.
The third thing that they have is that they
have local credibility. At the local level
people trust that priest or that pastor or
for that matter any mom or a rabbi; the religious
leader of their faith because he's marrying,
he's burying, he's helping them through the
stages of life. When the crisis comes NGO's
come and go, nations come and go, but for
instance the church has a 2000 year track
record.
So I really think that what we need to do
here at Davos is work on a three-legged stool.
The problem we haven't solved these issues
before is because we've had a two-legged stool.
We had government and business trying to work
together and that's a good thing, but the
two-legged stool will fall over.
You have to have the faith sector, you have
to have the public sector and you have to
have the private sector. And frankly, I don't
care why you do good as long as you do good.
You're motive may be politics. I'm a member
of the Council on Foreign Relations and I've
learned that, when you for instance, help
people get well if they've been unhealthy,
they like your nation. Now that's not my motivation
for doing good, but it's not a bad one.
If you have a political motivation fine, do
it. You may have a profit motivation for doing
good, well you know, some businesses say "we
are going to make drugs and make money at
the same time and help people." Great. I wish
more people would to that. I wish more businesses
would make more money and do more good at
the same time. It's not my motivation, but
a profit motive's not bad.
You might have a personal motivation. Maybe
you had cancer, you had AIDS and so you care
about people with cancer and AIDS.
My motivation is that Jesus said "love your
neighbor as yourself." It doesn't have to
be your motivation, I'm just encouraging you
to get involved. Do something now about the
problems of the world.